oh you know what i peeped as your alumni
the uh you're alumni you're an alumni
uh east l.a oh that that doctor
episode was pretty good we only watched
uh we watched two episodes i'm episode
six it's good pretty good you said it
was awful no i was
but they did one of uh community college
uh football in la and it was awful okay
compared to the original football oh god
i got it
but the basketball one's legit right
coach is dope huh the coach is dope
he's intense i like that though that
poor guy man that's the hardest he works
the walt head dude because he does he'll
have to coach
he has to mentor all those idiots
they're just [ __ ] up
he's the hardest job in the world he's
mentor these morons yeah
and then he has to because of the way
the school works since he gets full
salary then he has to teach there so he
teaches a
cycling class [ __ ] multiple times a
day
then he does bible study yeah then he
rushes home
yeah and he stays all the way in compton
god damn oh yeah he he lives in compton
such a long way
yeah because his church is crenshaw
right yeah yeah and and uh he lost he
lost he said
he was coaching the guy and he got
killed during the game about yeah so he
was like during the game
no during gang violence oh come on
though
i don't got shot during basketball well
i don't know it was dicey yeah yeah i'll
give you guys
well you was talking over there what are
you using i wasn't talking over here i
was just like what is it
during gang violence chappelle yeah gang
violence so he lost him he lost him he
said he'd never lose a kid like that
again that's why he invested oh yeah i
remember yeah
and then and then they said he could
coach david like he was coaching
division one he could be a head coach
division one
but the way division one works i mean he
was like i'll never see my family he's
like so i'd rather just be a head coach
at this community college
although i feel like he's doing more
like he's doing a lot like coach k
for duke's not teaching [ __ ] cycling
classes
then also the way those kids talk to him
i tell my girl i played big time
division
one football big time bro if i would
have said
one iota of like those kids talked to
him yeah
dude i would be kicked off the team so
[ __ ] well jesus
big guy that big guy he took him out he
was like man get me in the game man
uh not joe uh he was the one that played
at penn state and he got hurt and he
kept smoking that's why he was
that kid drives me [ __ ] nuts
he's a ball he's so weak mentally
yeah that he's never but even even after
that
[ __ ] up the tantrums the fouls where
he was kicking the cheers
yeah all that what's up he still has a
chance to go division one he's so
talented but he's somebody still
careful he can't he got hurt
at the division one yeah smoking weed he
starts smoking yeah
yeah and then that's good then how about
how about the point guard the light skin
feller oh he's like he's a beast i like
it he's a beast
but what's tough to see is 16. he's 6-2
point guard his
his he so his dad was in his life his
dad's black his mom's super white
his mom three years ago got cancer and
passed away
and they were they were like super close
yeah so then he's just on his own
and he's like he's a team captain he's
the heart of the team he's such a beast
hey my problem with him
not a problem what i was telling my girl
she's like man i hope he makes it he's
not
i said the chances of him making it to
forget the nba that it happened but even
nah that's not happening okay but well
maybe you don't think you can make
division one be tough dude that's a six
two point guard
but he is still curry right but his
shots are great
uh steph curry six four sir that's the
problem no yeah trust me
he said trust me i've met him me too
we're eye to eye i want to meet him
bring up how tall steph curry is i'll
help him with his luggage six four
six three two one
but this is the prom but steph curry oh
yeah you talking about the greatest
shooter of all time the nba
no there are guys that are six two of
maybe davidson on the map
yeah for sure you knew that i do i knew
that i followed his career yeah the
problem is my girl is like i hope he
makes it because i wanted to make money
be okay and i was like i know
the chance of him making it is not good
you see how they live on campus
i know oh the way they live on campus he
lives with his girl
far he lives all the way out in uh
riverside from from where the school is
from riverside it's like an hour and a
half and this girl are cute though
this is like yeah it's like it's like
it's right or down because it's east l.a
community college
i didn't know this it's a [ __ ] huge
school 35 thousand students
how many sc's private so that that one
has like eight thousand
ucla say like yeah maybe ten
thousand maybe let's go to that's like
miami it's not that big of a school
though
forty forty thousand four was there
forty four usc series
or usci no jesus christ and that's a
private
enrollment every single year or like in
total 2016.
that's a [ __ ] ton for a private school
that's
nuts that's how many different villages
when i went to
uh usc i only stayed with like my
particular college and the theater
school only had maybe like 100 200
kids oh okay so ucla is a public school
and they're 44 000.
that's weird for usc to be private at
44. ucla is harder to get into
depending on the field it is a little
more competitive in certain depending
yeah it depends what what you're going
into
like their nursing school is very
competitive what about communication
communication is i think easiest for
both schools
oh sc ucla
you guys have a better chance of me
because you're black but that's a white
guy
dude i know that's a white guy
asian dude hey you got a shot
uh went to ucla yep yeah which one my
cousin went to ucla as well she kept
it uh uh shawn did he want to be a
promoter the one that looks like
something just the one that looks really
like the light skin with the curls oh
the light skin one and the masterpiece
son went to
us usc yeah romeo miller yeah he played
he played ball there i didn't understand
his journey because he played ball at uh
usc and then he on commercial promoting
icdc college
oh yeah i remember here's the other
thing
would would he be on the team if his
dad's not p diddy
i don't know who he goes wait wait
son yeah no no no yeah
no masterpiece on can who oh no yeah
i tried to fight for him because i
thought he was a good player that's what
i'm saying hey yo let's go to my old
alumni game
you want to go to the game you know what
sad is no one's at the game
how about you teach my speed class he's
like all right for extra credit
anybody who goes yo
you need the credit you go and she goes
she leaves his camera shoes
i'm busy because i didn't say what day
it is she's like i can't go man
dude there's no had to be a [ __ ]
i hope the producer was like say no
there you go
there's more kids at a [ __ ] high
school game not even closer
there's nobody there you see them
meanwhile they're beasts yeah
some of them some of them that i mean
that that east l.a college basketball
team did you see that
but they're like thinking about but
they're you can't get used to a team
they're switching out every two years
yeah so there's no nucleus it's not like
sc or ucla
because they're only in juco they're
only allowed the two years only two
years and then everyone as far as like
everyone they're super selfish too like
their only goal is to get to another
college
yeah they don't give a [ __ ] about the
that's and that's just you know what it
does you know
that's why a coach is so good yeah such
a beast
every two years those kids are cycling
out you gotta redefine the team every
two years every two years
you know what's so crazy i saw that
white guy was shooting number three's
they couldn't stop oh i loved it i was
like what the white boy
what is it yeah
he got one bro and dude he was
bro you should be at duke what the [ __ ]
are you doing at jupiter
racing just every time they couldn't
stop i was getting
that team was a shitty team because they
were like oh they're like the weakest
team in the
world with a bunch of scrubs but he went
off though he went off
yeah like something there's there's
always something going on
i want to know his story how about how
about that one kid kj who's the number
one recruit in
all of california the what's the tall
black guy yeah
yeah and they're like there's no one
liking me six eight he should be there
like he should be
at whatever he is on top of that he
should be at whatever college he wants
to
and then you hear a story and you're
like oh my god there's a reason yeah
he's like yeah my friend you know he was
the number one recruit in
all of all of california which is big
time basketball he was number one ranked
recruit in all of california
he's like and then i just didn't uh pass
the summer class so
i didn't meet the standards to go to
division one you're like god dawg which
like don't they pretty much you know
you know they make them they make it
easy if you're an especially friend
yeah yeah the easiest make it easier if
you're a number one recruit oh dude you
literally just have to
you had to show up dude all you have to
do is show up and you'd probably be
playing at notre
dame or some [ __ ] what's wrong with you
you you are jay didn't do juco either
right no
damn no we like real education
yo yeah teachers are not gonna hate on
me for going
well it's metro state i don't think it's
a juco i don't think
i think it's a four-year call but he's a
professor at one my dad was he was yeah
oh your dad was a professor yeah what do
you think business
some business class is that what made
you want to get a business degree
no i like money oh okay we all do fair
enough
stage of the lap factory right away you
go bro
i figured out what you look like i'm
like what this wrote a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son